[موسيقى]
في معرض إكسبو 2020 ، كان الإرث في
قلب كل قرار تخطيط
وهو موجود في الجناح المغربي حيث
ستجد فكرة الإرث في
كل مكان
مستوحاة من قراها القديمة
باستخدام تقنيات بناء الأرض المتدفقة ،
حيث يدمج جناحها بين الكلاسيكية والرائعة.
البناء المعاصر حول الأرض هو حقًا
أقدم تقنية بناء يستخدمها
البشر على الإطلاق ، ما أردنا القيام به
هو رفع هذا التقليد من
اللغة العامية إلى بُعد صناعي تقريبًا
لاقتراح الأرض الصخرية
كبديل للخرسانة
كأطول جناح ريفي كما هو
وفقًا لذلك  لمصمميها ،
أكبر واجهة أرضية من نوعها
من نوعها ، تم بناؤها كقرية ، إنها 22 منزلاً
مكدسة فوق بعضها البعض ،
إنها تجربة بناء حيث
ترتبط كل هذه المنازل بشارع متعرج واحد ،
إنه مبنى به 10 حدائق
تظهر  ستقف جميع النظم البيئية في المغرب
كجناح قطري
في الوقت الحالي في غضون ستة أشهر  خذ
فرصة أخرى للحياة ، لقد صممنا بالفعل مبنيين في أحدهما سيتم تحويلهما إلى إسكان وهذا هو سبب تطويرنا
لمفهوم القرية ، كل من هذه
الأحجام التي تراها ستتحول إلى
شقق ثم الإحساس
بالمجتمع  بعد ذلك ، ستستمر عملية الإنشاء لفترة أطول
في ترك إرث دائم
لن يكون المغرب وحيدًا حيث تم التخطيط لموقع المعرض بأكمله
كمدينة مستقبلية وذكية
، نترك مدينة بأكملها
كإرث من
إكسبو مدينة تعيد تعريف المدينة بالكامل
التخطيط يعيد تعريف
الاستدامة تمامًا لاستخدام الحد الأدنى من المياه
بطرق مختلفة لبناء الطرق من
الإطارات المعاد تدويرها ، فإن طبقة
التكنولوجيا تتجاوز أي مدن أخرى في
جميع أنحاء العالم تاركة وراءها واحدة
من أكثر
مدن العالم تقدمًا من الناحية التكنولوجية ، يأمل إكسبو 2020
أن يستمر في القيادة  الابتكار بعد فترة طويلة
من انتهاء معرضه العالمي في غضون ستة أشهر ،
إيليني جوكاس سي إن إن إكسبو 2020 دبي